oh boy are they buying some time
[Music]
swing low Sweet Chariot come
hey dummies my palms can still work
I don't have to do I know you don't but
I get oh oh come to save the day good
now I can get rid of you too
Caitlin you can fight this I know but I
don't want it
[Music]
anything I search the whole building
she's gone
[Music]
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie it's a whole
bunch of flash related stuff happening
they confirmed a live-action Teen Titans
TV show written by Geoff Johns in the
Greg Berlanti arrowverse people and
Young Justice season 3 stuff
Simon explain what's going on if you
thought this morning's news was good
then this will blow you out of the water
they confirm that the people that make
the flash or making a live-action Teen
Titans TV show that will be called Titan
so they won't be quite so young they'll
be a little bit older Geoff Johns
himself will be riding on it he'll be
one of the writers of the TV show
probably one of the executive producers
as well so they are bringing their big
guns to bear I'm so happy that Jeff
Johnson's writing TV again but it will
premiere on DC Comics new digital
streaming service next year during 2018
along with wait for it Young Justice
Season 3 which is being called Young
Justice outsiders so if you haven't read
the outsiders comic book I'll explain
that too but let's talk about this
live-action Teen Titans TV show from the
people that make arrow flash Supergirl
in legends of tomorrow this is crazy so
they haven't said anything about the
lineup other than it will be led by Dick
Grayson aka Nightwing so they are doing
Nightwing on TV even though they're
going to do a Nightwing movie so that
means that they can also bring
Deathstroke on because he's a huge Teen
Titans character so manu Bennet best
keep his schedule open so now it's all
falling into place there were a lot of
complaints about the flash earlier this
season about how they're introducing too
many speedsters what's happening with
Kid Flash is he always going to be a
sidekick on the flash TV show because
Barry's always going to be the main
version of the flash we have Jesse quick
we have all these other characters
they're introducing in the only other
place for them to go with legends of
tomorrow and they just royally screwed
the timeline so now they just have
another place for some core big DC
characters to go so I should actually
say there is a new round of the flash
ring giveaway just because this is so
awesome and there is a new episode
airing tonight so I'll talk more about
this later as we get new information but
they haven't confirmed who the cast is
going to be only that they're starting
with the relatively classic lineup that
means Dick Grayson Nightwing Kid Flash
Wally West Aqualad and then they'll
probably add Raven and maybe Starfire
start
sort of the wild card most of the aliens
in the arrowverse come from Supergirl
just because she's from outerspace so a
lot of the villains that they face are
also from outer space so if they wanted
they could totally introduce Corey
through a Supergirl storyline but
there's any number of ways to explain
this and they haven't specifically said
how much crossover this digital
streaming show is going to have with the
other arrow for shows so there's a lot
of things that we don't know but like
Greg Berlanti is also doing the Black
Lightning TV show that's sort of
starting on its own they haven't said
how much it's connected to the other air
/ shows - so he's doing a lot of DC
shows and they haven't completely
confirmed how they're going to crossover
with the other TV shows the way they did
the day before night or three night
crossover technically this past winter
if you haven't been watching them DC
animation has been doing a lot of Teen
Titans movies you're probably at least
familiar with a couple of them their
lineup is a little bit different because
Damian Wayne is such a big part of the
animated DC Universe I think the odds of
them doing Damian Wayne on this
live-action show or zero I think they'll
just start with the classic Teen Titans
lineup and then build from there it just
depends on how everything goes but the
big thing here is the digital streaming
service like they talked about doing it
before it's through Warner Brothers but
it's just for DC comics stuff so they
haven't said how much it's going to cost
what other TV shows they're going to
stream on it but it'll be kind of like a
Netflix for just DC comics stuff so what
will probably happen is is when they
release new episodes there'll be one
episode at a time so of course Teen
Titans is like the biggest thing ever of
course I'm going to do videos for it but
there's a lot of talk about the flash at
the end of this season with a big twist
happening there's a lot of things that
could be explained with the addition of
a TV show that other characters can go
on but the other really big thing though
is that there are a couple key core Teen
Titans characters that they have not
introduced in the arrowverse yet so they
might say that for the pilot episode I'm
not expecting them to do like a backdoor
pilot like they did with the flash they
brought barry allen on on arrow and then
they started the flash TV show i don't
think it's going to be like that but
what they might do during the big four
night crossover for arrow flash
Supergirl in legends later this year
like later in 2017 is introduced the
idea of a couple of Teen Titans
characters it's just an opportune
for them if they want to take it but
they don't have to they can totally just
introduce all the Teen Titans characters
in the first episode of that TV show
whenever it premieres and I know they
said 2018 but that doesn't mean spring
it doesn't mean summer doesn't mean fall
it just means 2018 so it just depends on
how fast things move along and they
haven't said how many episodes it's
going to be I'm going to guess it'll be
at least 13 but it might not be like a
full 23 typically the streaming services
to longer episodes because they don't
have to put ads in between them but the
actual episode count is fewer so if they
did fewer episodes yeah I mean it would
kind of suck because it's fewer episodes
but they'd be able to spend more money
on each episode so more special effects
because if you're going to do Raven and
you have all this Trigon stuff you have
to show our powers it's going to take a
lot of special effects you got to do
Corey's powers you got to do these boys
powers so don't be surprised if there
are fewer episodes than there are a
flash arrow in the other live-action
shows but it's all speculation it's all
up in the air right now but what about
Young Justice Outsiders so that's what
they're calling season 3 they just call
it Outsiders so if you're not familiar
with it that's the name of another team
in DC Comics that's funded by Batman
with a bunch of other characters that
aren't members of other teams so really
none of the Young Justice characters are
members of The Outsiders in the comics
but what the team has become in more
recent years in the comics it's just
this ancient society dedicated to
eradicating corruption so what does that
sound like that sounds a lot like the
season 2 Young Justice plot with them
trying to get rid of the light so the
best thing you can do for Young Justice
to just catch up is to watch the Netflix
episodes all two seasons are on Netflix
they've already teased that the animated
version of Wally West the ginger Wally
West will be coming back to that TV show
but obviously live-action Teen Titans if
they're going to go with the Wally West
they might as well go with the Wally
West that we've been watching for the
last year on the flash TV show they'll
explain everything at Comic Con this
summer so them announcing it now it's
just them wanting to hype it up hey we
got a digital streaming service we have
two shows that you've been screaming
about for the last year so that means
they've been working on these TV shows
for a while and they'll probably have
some footage to show off at Comic Con
this summer so just be prepared for
things to get really crazy
in the best possible way so what will
happen next is I'll post my flash
episode later tonight leave all your
requests for Teen Titans young justice
bonus videos in the comments below while
you wait for that you can click here for
more flash and you can click here to
learn all about Avengers 4 the Infinity
Gauntlet thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you